hello and welcome back to game review my
name is Caleb Denby and today I wanted
to go over a game near and dear to my
heart this is the game where I actually
achieved the national master title let
me set the scene for you okay
so I had a I had a rating estimated
rating well over twenty two hundred
twenty to twenty or something going into
the end of this month where I achieved
the title and all I had to do was not
lose to ryan Deering Ryan Deering here
all I have to do is not lose he's around
eighteen nineteen hundred USCF Clare I
know him very well
he's a local here at the st. Louis chess
club and he was gunning for me he wanted
to take me out he wanted to crush my
national master dreams and I guess we'll
see we'll see how that worked out for
him huh so in the game I played d4 and
Ryan is usually a qgd player and and I
knew this about him so I have you know I
was throwing some hints that I had done
some deep prep for him in reality I was
just gonna play what I always played but
he was afraid so he plays c5 and I'm
blown away I'm taken aback at the board
but of course the bananas bad so I just
played the best moves which is d5 Knight
c3 and then he did something pretty
strange
he played d6 and after E for he didn't
play the move e5 and that's really the
only point to doing this move order here
much better for you benoni players out
there is to start with Knight f6 and
after white commits to c4 now you can
play your benoni stuff either with c5
first or six first and now c5 and now
white has committed to putting this pawn
on c4 it keeps this diagonal closed it's
kind of in the way for some maneuvers
for white it makes b5 a little bit more
powerful because you kind of have this
pawn to bite on to and so this move
order is much much better
the only reason really to play this move
order is if you're gonna do stuff like
'if I've on even on move to but Ryan
Dearing didn't play like this and said
he played Knight f6 and now after Knight
c3 I don't have to commit to this c4
move and it's just a little bit more
comfortable
for me with that in mind let's continue
he plays g6 here I develop my pieces he
develops his pieces I develop my pieces
he develops his pieces and here I
decided I liked this night because this
night controls dark squares and this
Bishop doesn't control dark squares so
why would I let him take this [ __ ] this
night with his Bishop I want to keep my
knight I want to put it somewhere nice
like c4
I want to control these central dark
squares that are very pivotal to the
position so Knight d2 we see a trade on
e two black castles I Castle now black
does actually play this c6 move trying
to put some pressure on to d5 I bring
this Knight to a very natural Square on
c4 and now black plays this move Queen
e7 moves just a little bit a little bit
off much more natural is to bring like a
rook to e8 maybe even bring this night
to e8 bring it out to c7 maybe capture
on on d5 is also very very standard
something like this followed by rook e8
would have been a more normal way of
playing instead though we see Queen e7
and Queen just doesn't really belong
here you know you see Queen c7 sometimes
sometimes you do see Queen e7 but this
Queen on this open file is honestly just
asking for trouble if black ever does
want to capture on d5 just asking for a
rook to land on the e1 square and kick
it away to his credit though he did make
a threat he's threatening to capture my
pawn so I simply play Queen f3 stepping
out of the threat adding another
defender to d5 Knight FD 7 was Ryan's
choice opening up this bishop but now I
get to play this move Queen g3 and
already I'm aiming at this d6 pawn which
is a little bit weak 95 was his choice
and now for you people who know a little
bit about chess you'll know if you have
more space you generally want to keep
pieces on the board so I wasn't at all
really interested in capturing this
night especially cuz after Bishop takes
Bishop takes e5 is
pieces are just a little bit more free
the fewer pieces on the board for black
kind of the better because my space
advantage doesn't matter as much so
instead I played Knight III avoiding the
trade Knight a six was Ryan's choice
coming to the c7 square just a little
unorthodox but you know there is a point
to it he wants to expand with b5 but now
I'll ask you at home to find the best
move for white and this is kind of your
make-or-break point here you have to
figure out what White's plan is what you
want to be doing and it's it's a very
common break in the Benoni it's worth
knowing
so go ahead pause the video see if you
can find it okay
here's the answer the best move for
white here is to go ahead and play f4
and a lot of you at home probably
guessed this f4 is a pretty familiar
pawn break but then let me ask you here
after 97 how many of you thought the
point was a 5 in the future because
that's actually not the point here ie 5
is a very common pawn break in the
Benoni
in Benoni structures but in this case
we're looking for a different pawn break
in fact this pawn break is almost more
common to my knowledge and especially in
structures like these the whole point of
white wanting to break with a move like
a 5 or this other move is that you want
to open up files in the center and
around blacks King you want to open
these files to make use of your extra
space and then create some definite
threats when material checkmate the King
things of that nature so in this case
black actually has a 5 well under
control there's just too many pieces
here I can't really get a 5 in so the
move I want to play is actually f5 and
this was the point of f4 so the point of
this night on e3 it's the point of this
work on on f1 you want to play f5 to
open up the position in this case it
also forces black to do something pretty
drastic about this pawn on e6 so he
plays he takes f5 I recapture of course
it would be a huge mistake for black to
recapture again because Knight f5 is
simply kind of winning the game you
don't want to open up the king like this
so instead we've seen
see seven from Ryan and now I play this
move Knight G for the point being I kind
of want to trap all of blacks pieces
with this very annoying move f6 just a
funny line for you let's say rook e8 I
go ahead and play f6 if you play Knight
takes I'll play Bishop g5 putting you in
an awkward PIN and if you play Bishop h8
I get to check me so this is the point
so in the game Ryan tried h5 with the
idea being that he could capture my
nernst I play the very nice move Bishop
f4 hitting this pawn on d6 and if you
capture me I'll capture your knight and
so black plays Knight to e5 and now
perhaps the best move is in fact to
capture this Knight but now I can play
the very nice in-between move f6 and of
course if you capture my knight I
capture your queen and this is the main
problem here for for black so black has
to capture but now after captures
captures white really has his his pick
of good moves here Bishop g5 is very
tempting 94 is very tempting I actually
chose not the best move but good enough
Bishop h6 a simple double attack
attacking the Queen attacking the rook
Ryan made the very strange decision to
come back to h8 perhaps the e7 square
was a bit better for this Queen but now
I simply capture this rook and after
rook takes Knight e4 and the threats are
kind of mounting around around the black
King the end is near we see Knight takes
d5 Knight to rook 81 h4 Queen g5 once
again really piling up on these dark
squares night before and now after rook
takes d6 and Knight see - we see Knight
f6 check King g7 and I get to pick up
this Knight and checkmate is very very
near and this is actually where where
Ryan decided to resign
so I succeeded I did not lose to Ryan
Deering thankfully my chest career would
have been cast in shame forever had I
lost this game but
luckily for me that didn't happen and I
did manage to achieve my title after
this game so thank you very much for
indulging me in this little remembrance
on my recent chess career as always my
name is Caleb Denby and I will see you
in the next episode of game review